that's why I keep saying my size rocks
this is my type
I'm not plus size I am my size Roxy
rocks the Real Housewives of Toronto
star is ready to stand up to body
shamers and push the body positivity
movement to new heights laughs if I'm on
a television show where people are
listening to me this is going to be my
legacy from that yeah some people
thought it was just gonna be a reality
show and to me it's become so much more
this isn't something I feel passionately
about it's a movement Roxy has always
embraced her fabulous curves since she
was a child but now having every second
televised it's hard when she sees body
ignorant like she did on last night's
episode but quite honestly I was feeling
really uncomfortable there there's
absolutely nothing that would even
remotely fit me I think I specifically
asked Kara if she'd have things that
would be appropriate for me to buy to
designers start embracing women of all
shapes and sizes of all colors of all
backgrounds this is just about diversity
and don't take my crying is weakness
I'm gonna change things I showed that
vulnerability yesterday when I made that
video because I want designers to listen
I have a platform here I have a platform
to change the way people look at fashion
hopefully one day create my own
wonderful collection yeah and fans and
celebrities are feeling it loving her
hashtag my size rocks they love
everything they're saying and everything
you're doing and that picture you posted
did Ashley Graham see that one as well
yeah and she reached out to me and sent
me some beautiful bathing suits of hers
and she's been really supportive and a
lot of people have been supportive